okay some very interesting discussions
happening on the David Pakman show
reddit at david pakman.com slash re d di
t the first one is from a user named
nostalgic san who says no disrespect but
can we truly expect these old candidates
to even survive for years trump Biden
Sanders are all late 70s I don't see
them living another four to eight years
Sanders had a heart attack Trump's a
walking cholesterol medicine
advertisement and Biden is seeming very
weird with his gaffe someone also adding
Bloomberg had stents while he had had
three stents put in Warren is no spring
chicken so listen I don't believe it is
ages to consider this and the truth is
when you look at life expectancy at
birth Bernie was born in 1941 Biden was
born in 1942 Trump was born in 1946 life
expectancy for people born in those
years was between seventy and seventy of
seventy-two when you account for so life
expectancy at birth tends to be lower
because it has to account for some
people who don't make it out of infancy
life expectancy once age 65 for people
born in the years that these folks were
born in is somewhere between twelve and
a half and thirteen more years so if you
in a very detached way look at the data
these are reasonable concerns now the
truth is that in the United States
economic class has a lot to do with life
expectancy and so when you get to these
numbers 77 78 you know once you account
for already being reaching the age of 65
it is probably quite stratified based on
your income level and economic class and
of course Bernie Biden and Trump are all
doing well economically I don't believe
it is ageist merely to ask these
questions and and I'm interested in
hearing more from folks about it another
user Philo 19:27 posted an article from
The Washington Post called or arguing
that an article from The Washington Post
points out that Trump has no clue what
to do in a disaster referring of course
to coronavirus I I am increasingly
concerned
not about coronavirus in the abstract
but specifically about Donald Trump's
ability to actually manage something
like a massive outbreak or pandemic and
we're going to get to it in more detail
later today I know a lot of you were
worried about it because of the number
of posts about it on the David Pakman
reddit the number of emails I'm getting
from you the number of tweets I'm
getting from you I agree
Trump has no clue how to deal with the
disaster remember in Puerto Rico after
the hurricanes he went and shot rolls of
toilet paper like basketballs and had no
idea what to do it's it's it's a major
problem and we're going to address it
more in a moment
lastly from the reddit user Dennis
Hopper says South Carolina is a turning
point arguing that South Carolina is
going to be a place that has two
outcomes either Bernie wins and becomes
the favorite to win not just a plurality
but a majority of the delegates or Biden
wins gaining delegates and taking
momentum away from Bernie muddying the
waters heading into Super Tuesday I am
les decided that South Carolina will be
a turning point i I think that because
there's only two days between South
Carolina and Super Tuesday I think Super
Tuesday is the turning point and I
believe that after Super Tuesday we will
see either a very clear path to a
contested or brokered convention a
negotiated convention because more
people will have delegates we might
Michael Bloomberg will have delegates
after Super Tuesday maybe Tom Styer will
that's one scenario or Bernie will clean
up on Super Tuesday and it will very
much look like nobody will be able to
catch him I believe Super Tuesday is the
turning point join the discussion at
david pakman.com slash reddit nearly
18-thousand can you imagine nearly
18,000 of our viewers and listeners
subscribed free of course there's no
charge to participate no entry fee at
all participating in the David Pakman
show reddit